Yes, we're here.
Tell us your yarn of your potion.
Before you, you find Malachite Mirabilis.
Malachite Mirabilis, my favorite!
How did you know?
The one true potion that allows
lovers to release their woes
and find their one true love.
Oh!
Guinevere and Lancelot, Prince Charming
and Sleeping Beauty.
All peed in this?
Jealous!
The potion that has been used to awake lovers to one another for years
and grow and change and transform
through that love.
Malachite, the stone of transformation.
Often known to elicit feelings of joy
and allow you to be able to
release what ails you
and move to what will heal you.
Let her cook!
And so when you drink this
not only will you be able to heal
from your trauma
and release what ails you
but move towards the things that give you joy
and also it has
a side benefit
of being able to
take the burden to God.
Wow, that's fantastic.
Jester, what did you offer to the team today?
I gave the good spirits to the
gods who gave us the wonderful ingredients.
Failed wizard, what have you offered
the team?
So, I tried
to do a coin spell.
When you taste it, it might have worked a little bit
but my magic was not quite powerful enough.
So looking for a nice coppery flavor perhaps?
Perhaps, but
I was going for a freezing spell
and so it might be a little cheap.
It might be a little chilly
but I wasn't quite there
so try it before
the spell wears off.